oh good to have you on again thanks for
being here it's nice to be here you know
what I actually have the same dream
about the somebody coming into my house
this happens a lot actually where I'll
be just falling asleep and I'll think
I'll run through an entire scenario of a
home invasion and I don't have any kind
of weapon in my house so you want to go
with the 22 caliber right on of the
shooter in the house to low caliber gun
you can't really kill anybody from a
distance you know so if they take a
hostage you can just start shooting at
them perfect on the road I talked about
getting a 22 everybody makes fun of me
you know cuz they you know it's that guy
thing like Oh were you gonna shoot a
squirrel well you little you know a
little gun but if you're ever in a house
that that's what you want a little 22
you know I'm basically teaching you guys
how to kill somebody I think so it's the
22 you think it's superior to the way
you want to get a lot of a
vacuum-cleaner 44 Magnum it's like
you're gonna shoot through the guy
through the wall blow your dog's brains
out like drop the engine of your car way
too much little 22 you can still hear if
you miss no I shot a 38 one time with no
hearing with no hearing protection yeah
I was doing landscaping for this guy and
all of a sudden it was like I got this
five shot 38 I never shot it it was the
80s so you like you can't explain
anything by just said oh is the 80s what
did you do that it was the 80s we went
down the street that somebody burned a
car for insurance so we were shooting at
that and after the first shot I couldn't
hear anything and I never forgot that so
if you're in the house and you miss now
you can't hear you're blinded by the
muzzle flash this guy's coming around
your bed with a sickle and you shoot
is he harvesting
she doing in your house I know I I
honestly as you get older you think
about safety and like I totally relate
to that yeah when you're home alone it's
just that feeling yeah it's just you're
the only person there your yard's you're
what's for dinner if somebody comes in I
never was comfortable in a motel Wes
because you're just laying in this bed
like two feet from a door anything that
just opens up into the parking lot any
guy can come in and you're just not
ready to have a fight to the death you
just lay in there I'm never ready to
have a fight to the death it's not you
think in a motel it's like that's you're
particularly vulnerable tell you should
be you know just drive by a motel just
look at it you're just looking at those
doors like this just people in there
just laying on beds like half naked you
know just laying there is like it's
merely you could put your foot right
through it
he's gonna be like that that's it last
thing you're gonna see is just you're
gonna be looking back at your own body
like
I do I can think about that